[Música]
casi 50 millones de personas viven en
esclavitud moderna y esta es la cifra
del 2021 ese es uno de los hallazgos del
índice global de esclavitud que realizó
la organización internacional
en este estudio que analizan la
situación de 160 países se desglosan
muchas nuevas informaciones el informe
muestra además que entre el 2016 y el
2021 se incrementó la cifra en 10
millones de personas nos acompaña María
collazos quien es analista y también
investigadora para Walk free en peart
Australia occidental Muchísimas gracias
a usted por estar con nosotros María y
Comencemos si le parece bien haciendo
una gran Claridad sobre lo que es la
esclavitud moderna porque muchas veces
no sabemos diferenciarla de lo que sería
un trabajo normal de cualquier persona
en el mundo
Buenas noches Ángela Cómo están Mira la
esclavitud moderna se refiere a
situaciones de explotación y las
personas no pueden y no pueden abandonar
y
debido a amenazas a actos de violencia
abuso de poder
y se manifiesta de diferentes formas y
se conoce con diferentes nombres como el
trabajo forzado la servidumbre por
deudas Y trata de personas explotaciones
sexual forzada explotación sexual
comercial de niños niñas y adolescentes
ahora la diferencia entre la esclavitud
moderna del día de hoy de la esclavitud
histórica que conocemos radica en que en
el pasado y muchos casos existían Marcos
legales que permitían
que esta clase de prácticas se
manifestaran hoy en día en ninguna
jurisdicción en el mundo del esclavitud
moderno Es legal y sin embargo tenemos
más esclavos que en cualquier momento la
historia de la humanidad 28 millones de
personas están en el trabajo forzoso en
situaciones de trabajo forzado y 22
millones de personas viven en
matrimonios sin su consentimiento
claro lo que pasa es que aquí Quisiera
hacer la aclaración o que usted nos
ayude a diferenciar porque es tan
difícil entender estos casos cuando una
persona está bajo coacción Pues cómo va
a aceptar que está en una condición de
esclavitud moderna o cuando no tiene
esta misma persona que está haciendo
coaccionada el conocimiento de sus
derechos y de su situación no Por eso
pasan tan por debajo del tapete miles y
miles de casos y quisiera preguntarle
específicamente por la India son 11
millones de personas que se contabilizan
en esclavitud moderna y podrían ser
muchísimas más por otro lado hay países
que están mejores flanqueados como Suiza
como Noruega Cuál es la diferencia entre
estos dos polos que hacen los mejores o
los peores países calificados
Ángeles es una pregunta muy interesante
y es las situaciones varían respecto a
diferentes condiciones de riesgo de
vulnerabilidad en diferentes países
India por ejemplo cuando calculamos el
número de personas en esclavitud moderna
de acuerdo al número de habitantes del
país encontramos que en el 2021 ocho
personas de cada mil personas en el país
se encontraban en alguna situación
Ahora si analizamos la situación de
otros países
como Corea del Norte esta cifra
incrementa ciento cuatro punto seis
personas por cada mil habitantes la
diferencia es que India tiene un número
de habitantes muchísimo más alto lo cual
nos hace ver las citas absolutas de
esclavitud moderna
unas cifras muy altas como la que usted
presenta
Pero hay factores como la inequidad el
sistema de castas
normas culturales que permiten que
situaciones de escrituras no se
presentan en el día de hoy en países
como India Ahora hay países como Noruega
como Suecia como los Países Bajos y
Alemania y los que tienen sistemas
legales mucho más fuertes y sistemas de
protección de derechos humanos y
protecciones sociales para poblaciones
vulnerables mucho más abarcantes que las
protegen de la esclavitud modernas
Hasta qué punto es o debe ser más fuerte
la cultura que la institucionalidad y
que la corriente de los Derechos Humanos
porque hay un caso muy específico y es
el de los matrimonios arreglados o los
matrimonios forzados
que ese Ese es todo un tema en los
países donde están normalizado que una
niña no solo contraiga matrimonio sino
que sea mamá y aquí pues es muy duro
para las instituciones que no son
fuertes combatir estos fenómenos y eso
pasa mucho en América Latina por ejemplo
Sí el matrimonio forzado es un problema
muy muy complejo Además porque mire hay
una diferenciación entre matrimonio
forzado y matrimonio arreglado no todos
los matrimonios arreglados son
matrimonios cruzados cierto sin embargo
hay matrimonios arreglados que son
forzados a los que las personas entran
en contra de su voluntad
y las normas culturales y los valores de
familias son mucho más influyentes que
las
leyes o los sistemas legislativos sin
embargo tomar medidas legislativas como
la prohibición y la criminalización del
matrimonio forzado para mujeres adultas
y niñas y el prohibir el matrimonio
forzado para personas menores de 18 años
sin ninguna excepción es el primer paso
que los países pueden empezar a tomar
para empezar a cambiar estas prácticas
ahora ya cambiar los valores culturales
y las prácticas culturales de muchas
comunidades indígenas
o o en países como Indian los que es muy
normal porque se considera normal que
una niña se casa antes de los 18 años
toma más tiempo pero que debemos que el
cambio a nivel legislativo ese es un
paso importante y es el primer paso que
las naciones tienen que empezar a dar ya
como conclusión es muy rápidamente
Quiero preguntarle cómo nos toca a
nosotros esta realidad y qué
responsabilidad debemos asumir al ser
consumidores de muchos productos que
provienen de la esclavitud moderna y por
muchos le diría casi todos
tiene todos los personajes
se encuentra en todos los aspectos de
nuestra vida cotidiana y no lo sabemos O
sea no somos conscientes del costo
humano en los productos que consumimos
desde la ropa que nos ponemos hasta el
azúcar que usamos en el café cada mañana
la batería del celular que usamos
las las plataformas de redes sociales
que sirven como para la trata de
personas que se utilizan para la trata
de personas solo comercialización sexual
y la explotación sexual y comercial de
niños niñas y adolescentes en todo el
mundo es un caso muy alarmante y es un
llamado para una mayor regulación
regulaciones de consumo y también en las
cadenas de suministro de todos los
países
María collazos analista e investigadora
para Walk free Empire Australia
Muchísimas gracias a usted y la
invitación para nuestros televidentes a
que revisen que estamos consumiendo y De
qué manera lo estamos consumiendo ya
volvemos con más de directo a América
[Música]